PG so happy that you're here um this is
already one of our favorite interviews
because it included a free trip to
Hawaii so thank you for having us uh how
refreshing is it to have training camp
in such a beautiful place like this yeah
it's awesome you know because you get a
bit of both you get vacation and you get
to work extremely hard um to start the
year off so um I think it's awesome it's
easy to break the two um when we're in
the gym we know what we're in there for
once we leave there we know why we're
we're out of that uh out of that for so
um you know it's it's just been great
and uh I think what I love most about it
the Clippers organization do an amazing
job of including the families and and
tying everyone together um and you know
the tradition in Hawaii is very family
cultured and I think it's it ties into
you know what the Clippers are trying to
do as well so it's it just hits
everywhere yeah and I mean you know so
many of the headlines Clippers Stars
Paul George and Kawhi Leonard are
entering training camp completely
healthy what is it like to hear that out
loud oh man it's uh you know it's great
you know anytime you know myself
especially I can start a season off
without having to rehab something um and
I could just die right into you know
trying to get off to a great start the
better and you know very fortunate Qui
is the same way he's feeling the same
way he's healthy um and you know we
don't have to start the year off trying
to catch up at any point like we're all
in from the day the ball has jumped up
so um it's great you know honestly it's
great I think everybody around us feels
it our teammates feel it um you know and
just to build chemistry with Russ to
start the year off is very important so
um you know it's it that's that's you
know we we definitely look at that as as
a blessing to start the season healthy
what level of pressure do you feel
headed into this
season not more than any other season
honestly um for me I haven't won a
championship yet um so I can't even say
that like the pressure isn't always to
win it um that's first and foremost and
again it I can't say that we've
underperformed um and so there's no
pressure there that we've underperformed
and didn't give ourselves the a chance
to win it um fact of the matter is I
mean I've had fluke injuries you know uh
my elbow
um getting you know falling on and and
and messing my UCL up or my knee getting
kicked back and and now I'm missing
postseason um same with Kawai has an
injury in postseason so we haven't
really had or or gave ourselves a chance
just due to injuries um so there's no
pressure like it's not that we're not
getting to the moment and shying away
from it we just haven't been able to
stay healthy for the moment now okay I
want to talk about what you just said
because I'm sure some people will hear
that and have questions when you said
you feel like you all have not
underperformed I think maybe some NBA
fans would consider some of the seasons
as an underperformance why do you feel
differently in terms of what just in
terms of maybe you know what you all
wanted to accomplish having both you and
Kawai on the team how far people wanted
you to go and I agree that there has
been injuries but I just want you to
talk a little bit more about why you
don't view it as underperforming yeah
well I mean I know people love looking
at Stats and looking at you know looking
at this from a analytical standpoint um
analytically when we're healthy I think
we've lost three games four games
something like that um you know we've
been very productive and very successful
when healthy and both of us are on the
court at the same time um that's just
what we're trying to battle now it's
it's is remaining healthy um and so you
know when you look at that I mean we're
I'm we're carrying what we can when when
I'm not when when he's on the floor and
I'm not on the floor he's car heing what
he's what he can for the lack of me
being there and vice versa um but when
we're there together we're picking that
load up and we're you know carrying our
team past the the line um sort of say
and and and we got help I'm not going to
say it's on just my myself and Kawai we
have a huge help from Russ now from
Marcus from Nico roko T-man Zoo you know
lisco on Bones um we have a ton of help
but um you know we just haven't quite
been able to do it fully
uh for us not being healthy for a whole
season I always think about and not to
put words in your mouth I just think
about how annoyed I would be that people
are almost trying to make you and kawhai
like the face of load management as if
you all don't want to play or you
wouldn't play if you could exactly does
it does it feel annoying to you it's
annoying it's annoying cuz ultimately
like we love basketball you know we love
to play We love to compete like that's
just how we are we love to to hoop um
but for people to say that you know oh
they're they're not going to play
they're they're missing game like we
don't intentionally want to miss games
obviously there's something going on or
obviously we it's something that we're
trying to uh you know be mindful of and
be ahead of um and you know it's not
just us that are that it's not just
players that's involved in on those
decision it's you know it's Med or not
media it's uh uh medical staff it's you
know High ups that that have say so in
these situations as well um you know
obviously I feel players can override it
but we're mindful of our bodies um and
so yeah it gets annoying hearing noise
of are they going to play are they not
going to play like you know if we
haven't played or if we're not suiting
up there's something that's going on
that's that's keeping us out of that
game yeah you're like if I'm not playing
I didn't have a choice exactly exactly
absolutely um Russell Westbrook is one
of my favorite players to watch and I
think he's also one of the more
misunderstood players in this league you
know him very well you've known him for
a very long time what do people have
wrong about Russ that Russ is a winner
honestly Russ brings a winning culture
um Russ plays hard Russ is a great
teammate great locker room guy I think
that's what
people don't get to see because you're
you're not with Russ on a day-to-day
basis what you see from Russ is him
being on the court um and him in game
like you don't see what he he brings the
value that he brings to a team um and
being on the same team with him for
multiple years now um the reason why I
wanted to bring him over with us uh with
the Clippers is I just saw it from afar
joining that Oklahoma team being outside
looking in just the way he connected
with everybody was was inspiring like it
brought out the best of everybody and um
you know I I thought we could have used
that um in our locking room um and and
you need a leader at the point guard
position you know I always love seeing
the videos of you and Kawai together
because it feels like you one of the
people that he is just most comfortable
with like every personality moment that
I see with Kawai you're also there why
do you think you all have that
connection what about you makes Kawai
feel so comfortable um good question I
don't know um you know I guess you know
I I I get them I understand them um I
Vibe with him you know we're on the same
page with one another um you know
there's just a mutual respect there you
know um and uh again I feel like I allow
him to be himself um with no judgment no
you know
expectations um you know I just
appreciate you know uh who he is and and
what he's done in his league and so you
know I I don't know um he's so like un
everything he says it's like he's not
trying to make a joke but it's hilarious
yeah but that's that's Kawai like that's
kaai um I think people don't realize
like he is as normal as possible and
he's a funny dude and he's you know
charismatic and he has a personality
like I don't know why people undermine
that he's just a like think he's a robot
like that's the craziest thing to me um
before you met him did you also think he
was a bit of a robot
uh No I gave him the benefit of the
doubt you know I gave him the benefit of
the doubt uh but at the same time I
didn't know much about him yeah um and
you know there's always a mystery if
you've seen the memes memes is going on
way before we were teammates of him and
his personality but then being a
teammate of his oh like he's normal if
anybody else yeah I like this guy yeah
he actually talks a lot like when you
get to know him he actually talks a lot
he's he's cool you know really really
down toe dude um and so yeah we just we
hit it off and we just connect that's
great no I I love the friendship that
you all have um one of my just general
favorite moments from last season was
Giannis in the postseason talking about
his definitions of success and failure
and I really liked it because it's clear
to me that every NBA player has a
different definition of both of those
words and it can't be defined by anybody
other than you so from your perspective
when you think about your time with the
Clippers do you define it as a success
or a
failure I mean I there there is two ways
to look at this right um like successful
year for me back when I was 22
23 24 years old uh the younger Paul
success for me regardless if we want it
or not was me getting better and and and
developing every season right making an
All-Star appearance um late playoff
pushes being all NBA that was a
successful year for me um but then now
where I'm at in my career now not
winning a championship on a yearly basis
when you have a team that is more than
capable of it um you come up short you
felt you fail the year you know you you
fail the year now granted I can still
get better I can still make all stars I
can still be all NBA that's the
expectation at that point you know what
I mean I'm not expected to win you know
I don't I don't think anyone expects to
win you got to work for it you have to
earn it um and if you don't win you
failed that year um and so that that's
just how I look at it now at this point
in my career and I 100% agree with with
giannis's take on that um but you know
it people can look at it differently one
thing that was really clear to me just
as I was prepping for this is it feels
like right now for you there is a big
focus on Legacy and what you want people
to believe about your presence in this
league
what is it about Legacy right now that
is really in your brain what scares you
about Legacy or about how you want to be
remembered yeah I think uh I think you
know I'm naturally just a good dude um
and I feel like in this league it kind
of just been taken for granted um people
you
know feel like you know I'm not the same
because of injuries or because of I
haven't won or
one bad experience in the playoffs that
you know I I'm not good enough to you
know still be a one option or two option
or 25 30 point scorer or top defender on
the floor like there's been a lot of
questions for whatever reason floating
around the air about me and uh it always
baffled me you know of why why why like
and so that's just Legacy at this point
now is is just proven
my spot um and and and you know
regardless you know I if we win we don't
win that's out of my control I'mma give
everything I have to win a championship
and do whatever I can to win one um but
if I come up short my legacy now is
being all right I did what I could I I
gave it my all um I know how I approach
the game I want to be the best on both
floors I want to guard the best every
night um that's still how I present
myself when I touch the floor um um and
so now for my legacy is just I I want
that to be what people recognize he
played hard he didn't shy away from the
matchup um and offensively he you know
was a threat you know he made the game
better um he was a joy to watch um
entertaining um and he just played his
heart out um and and that's just you
know I'm not
taking you know uh no for an answer I'm
not backing down to nobody um and going
forward you know my presence will be
felt on the
floor you said something off top that
was interesting you said that you know
people feel like I'm this really good
guy and that has maybe in some ways
clouded how they talk about how you play
and what ways do you feel like maybe
this kindness or this kind of outside
Persona has been seen as a weakness for
you it just been a lot of barking um a
lot of barking for and again it's been
guys that that that are in the same
position as me like you know I I view
like all right you you won a
championship you've been to the the peak
you've been to the top I get it like I'm
that's where I'm working towards um and
I'm not a talker you know I'm I'm not
the
initial um now if you say something
I'mma I'mma say back I'mma say it back
I'm a counter for sure uh and I I just
feel like that's just where I'm at with
it um you know now it's just to the
point where all right like we we all
gota like trying to get to the same same
point you know we're all trying to get
to the top and so you know again just
comes down to the noise that's just been
in the league um and you know it's been
documented it's been highlighted I don't
have to touch on those but I just I hear
the noise and uh it's just you know it's
gotten to a point where like at some
point all right now you now you woke the
bully I have the bully what is the one
noise or one narrative that you've heard
that you have taken the most personally
that you feel is the most
incorrect uh I would say probably just
that I'm I'm not a playoff performer um
again I had one one experience again
that was documented during the bubble
that I I didn't play my my best I
struggled um and that kind of you know
has floated with me um you know and and
there's been other playoff moments where
I was playing through injuries that I
think people was like oh he's he's not
this well you didn't know where I was
dealing with at that time um but I think
you know more than anything that's when
basketball is most important and uh when
you spoke about the Legacy and touched
on that I think that's where Legacy is
made and so uh that's that's just the
the the most important the most
important uh questions that will be
answered for me yeah I mean I feel like
is really you know kind of heightening
the mission that you're on this season
cuz it's it's clear you you've really
kind of like internalized and taken it
personally in terms of I need to change
what these words are is that accurate it
is uh it is uh not not that it's just uh
not that like I'm out to you know change
people's opinion like I'm not how I
prepare this this season is how I
prepare every season that's just to get
better but I think
I I can't lie to say there's just a
little bit more Focus uh going into this
year on again how I start and how I
finished the Year and I love that you're
like okay I think you said what this is
I'm on my bully this year I love
that quote um but there was another part
of this interview with Slam Magazine
that you did that I thought was super
interesting you were talking about young
PG and you said that's the separation
between myself where I'm at now and the
younger me I just had that passion to
want to be the best and Destroy any
everything in front of me and it feels
like you're back to that in this moment
but before today when did that
change um I think uh it changed I think
going again going into the offseason um
going into the off season again you know
I had a lot of injuries a lot of stuff
going on rehabbing um I haven't quite
had many
Summers since I broke my leg where I can
use the whole summer to get better
um you know every summer I had I was
rehabbing something I mean even this
summer granted I had a a head start
because I got hurt you know what March
so I had a early uh you know summer of
rehab for myself um and so once I got
out of that it was kind of like early
summer when season was off uh to to
really work on my game so I haven't had
a long time or many Summers to really
work in and in hone in on on on my my
skill set um in a very long time and so
I just felt like you know this summer
was was huge for me um my body was in a
great
position uh and I did it uh I was able
to do a ton of just basketball work um
going into this season now um and so it
just put me in a mindset of
like yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm back on that
like I'm back on that wanting to
dominate wanting to be the best on the
floor the best that I can be the best
version of myself
and I don't care who I offend I don't
care about friendships on the court I
don't care about uh you
know just you know I like that Persona
of being cool is gone it's out the
window um and so yeah like I I I just
want to you know I'mma compete at a high
level and try to be the best version of
me I love that what season of your NBA
career most contributed to your personal
growth um
I would
say probably my going into my third year
um was the biggest growth uh for me
Danny Granger got hurt I stepped into
the role of being uh the number one
option
offensively um and that was just the
most that was a make or break you know
season for me um I could have forever
been you know a rooll guy and and never
quite met you know my PE
um or who the player I wanted to be not
the player that the Indiana Pacers
thought that I would be but the player
that I wanted to be um and I was able to
find myself in this league um roll with
myself with ultimate confidence and uh
you know I just learned a lot um and so
I would say that was that that that's
when I knew I was ready for any
adversity that I could I could I could
handle it and uh it set myself up for
where I am now in my career who is that
player that you ultimately want to be
and how close are you to that player
um I I mean I you never know like you
know I I have a vision of who I want to
be um but that you know changes like
season to season like this year all
right I want to be better at this I want
to be better at that um but then you go
out there you play like it might present
itself completely different um based off
how you have to play for your team you
know I you know I remember when uh uh
when Kawai went down um like you know I
wanted to be you know a certain type of
player Kawaii goes down now I'm asked to
be more of a point guard and get put in
a new role and you know uh you know just
a lot more ball handing a lot more
playmaking um and so you just never know
where it turns and you just have to be
prepared for whatever it is and again I
say that to say that year three helped
me prepare for whatever moment was
brought to me to to to to be able to
handle that um and so again to answer
your question I don't know it it always
changes um I just again it go always
just goes back to just wanting to be the
best player that I can be and wanting to
challenge myself to to to compete on
both ends at the highest level I can you
know one thing about you that has always
um I want to say bothered me but maybe
has always bothered me about the way
that people talk about your game is that
when they talk about you in the playoffs
or they talk about your performances
they're almost belittling the things
that you have had to go through you are
really honest about what you went
through in the playoffs you have also
been very honest about how hard injuries
are for you and I think that those
things aren't always put into account
when they talk about Paul George as a
whole I remember I had a conversation
with an athlete once just talking about
injuries and he said the thing that
sucks about injuries is it feels like
your body has betrayed you and it sticks
with me because I felt like betrayal was
such like a personified and specific
word to talk about an injury MH has that
has that been what it's felt like for
you like your body betrayed you in those
moments yeah yeah it has and that's that
was the toughest thing for me because
all my life like especially since I've
been in the NBA I won't say all my life
cuz I had to grow into my body and and
and as I got older and and and stronger
uh physically I've been gifted to move
the way I've been able to move um but
since I've been in League that's all
I've heard oh you're amazing mover you
move so well you run like a gazelle you
you know can contort your body and and
do all of these things right um You have
quick feet like all of this stuff I've
I've I've been told and and now I'm on a
court and I and I feel what they're
saying like oh yeah like I am pretty
good at this I do move great or um and
then when an injury happened and then
it's like dang like I can't do what
naturally I'm I'm so good at doing like
I can't stop on the dime and cut and you
know I can't jump and like and so it it
it it it does suck when you when you're
facing injuries and you're competing at
the highest level and you're in the
playoffs where it matters most and the
noise is loud outside from media you
know and and it's just like damn like I
I you don't know what to do in those
situations you want to scream out and
you know tell the world like hey this is
what I'm going through but at this day
and age it's viewed as an excuse and and
all of this and and if you're out there
obviously you can play through it um and
that's how people view it um but it but
it isn't as black and white it's it's
not as black as white it's not as black
as white and at times it is tough you
know I remember the Portland series you
know I had both shoulders operated on
that summer uh after that season but
going through that moment like I didn't
pick up a basketball for like two weeks
leading up into the playoffs and my
first experience is is playoffs now like
since you know getting shot up and
taking medicine to to to you know get
through the pain and stuff like that so
um and that's just what guys go through
and I think people don't understand that
um like when when guys have surgeries
right after the season you know it was a
lot going on for them to to get ready
and and for them to play through it um
and so that that just needs to be
highlighted where people understand what
we go through yeah I think that like
people mistake that something happening
often means that it's normal but those
aren't the same thing yeah right it's
like you can have these injuries and
you're seeing guys like play through
them it's just that that happens it's
not that it's easy yeah and so and I I
think it's hard for people to understand
that those two are aren't always the
same thing but you just explained it
really perfectly MH um what role does
your son's existence play in this idea
of Legacy for you everything everything
um I mean hopefully uh I can continue to
play another at least four or five years
um to the point where he can watch and
and and realize all right Dad played dad
was a NBA guy really good in basketball
like hopefully that there's a world for
that right um
and so you know everything I do at this
point is you know I want to make him
proud you know I want to to be a great
influence on him um and so he's
everything to do with my legacy at this
point um because I want to set the bar
for him to go after you know if he
doesn't become a basketball player so be
it you know that's not where our
relationship will ever end on um but if
he does I want to I want it to be a mark
where
something he chases something he's after
obviously I want him to be different
than me I want him to to to be the man
of him of his own right um but it it it
it it it's awesome to to lay the
foundation for him to pick it up and
take it further and there are a number
of Paul georgees in your family correct
correct yeah how many I'm the fifth the
youngest my son is the six um wow so
there's only three my dad uh myself and
my son okay and so this idea right of
name of what hearing the name Paul
George what you want people to feel when
you hear that name what do you want them
to feel um it's just you know a
uh a name of of strength you know um you
know I feel like there's a ton of
respect around my dad and and amongst
his friends and how people view him um
and I watched him as a kid interact with
people and um Um how my friends
interacted with him how you know uh you
know just everyone that interacted with
my dad it was just always positive and
love and respect and you know they just
viewed my dad as as you know just a a
great human being um and so seeing that
as a kid it's like all right like that's
what Paul George is that's what Paul
George that's a brand you know what I
mean that's a Paul George brand and so
it just that's kind of just how I go
about things like love respect um
humility uh you know all of those core
core things is what I want to pass down
you know to my son um you know I just so
happen to be in a different position
than what my dad was at at at in his
life um but all of the core valuables
should still stick the same and and and
credit my dad for that um he he gets the
ultimate credit for that yeah that's a
really beautiful answer I love that
thank um I know that you are a big gamer
um Ronnie 2K was recently talking about
you in NBA 2k and he said that he's not
sure if you're the best NBA NBA 2K or
now did you see this article not sure I
didn't see that he said he's not sure if
you're the clearcut anymore and he
actually said he doesn't know if Devon
Booker is better than you ah
um well only one way to find out would
you would you play Devon in an NBA 2K
game nah we got to check Rock differ
we got to check Rock definitely okay
well after that would you then
play um nah okay Noah so I'm asking this
because as a media member I know what it
can be like to do a show and somebody
has a thought about the show that you
did and then you're like well what do I
do now I know that obviously you and
Devon had this moment about the Klay
Thompson interview is there anything
that you would want to clear up about
that moment have you all been to speak
is it is the root of this that I mean I
just you know I I don't know where it
took the turn
um I don't know where it took the turn
you know things got heated when we
played Phoenix conversation
sparked and it wasn't it it came from
that end again this goes down to respect
lineing me and de Devon always been good
um you know he was
lil bro when he came in the league you
know um and then all of a sudden you
know temperature changed um and to where
now it's it's it's a line that was
passed uh you know stepped over the line
um and so like now it's just you know it
is what it is at this point
um uh but you know to go off that
question it was just you know me asking
clay you know he said um obviously it
was it was about that moment and I
forget what question I asked him but his
answer was his answer you know I wasn't
looking to you know if you watched the
Pod I'm never looking to to to do
clickbait stuff or you know have someone
say something that's going to raise
questions um he honest he he answered it
from an honest perspective that he you
know as another uh young man in this
game um you know making a name for
himself making a Way Paving way like
whatever Clay's answer answer was that
was his answer cool right um I wasn't
looking to pick or or di I would have
said something myself if that was the
case um but again he took it upon
himself to be seen or heard in that
moment cool now it is what it is um it's
it's it's it's stuck if it's up then
it's
stuck no I mean I get it like I said I
have somewhat been in that position
before I think you're great I think
Devon is great I would love for there to
be some sort of you know resolution but
as you said things can always be
resolved on a on a basketball court so
AB so I totally get it um last one for
you I read something where you were
saying that you know winning a
championship with the Clippers would far
outweigh winning a championship with
something like the like like with the
Lakers and I know obviously that is your
goal this year is to win a championship
why does winning one with the clippers
mean a little more to you um I mean just
CU it hasn't been done you know it
hasn't been been done it' be awesome to
be that group um um and for a lot of
reasons I mean Clippers I feel like has
have been through a lot of bad luck um
whether it's injuries whether it's uh
you know playoff uh bad luck of you know
being up 3-1 uh I know I've been a part
of uh some of that um but I just feel
Clippers with all the bad luck that they
face the adversity the the organization
have been through um it'll be nice to to
kind of be um you know that sun sh for
an
organization um and to be remembered as
the first group to to raise uh that
Banner um for the Clippers um there's a
unbelievable uh Community unbelievable
fan support from Clippers um and uh you
know we feel it you know we we feel it
we feel how bad Clipper Nation wants to
win um and we want to be a part of that
so I think that's what what raises or
bring value to me to win it with with
the Clippers amazing I love that well I
didn't get a chance to talk to you about
your podcast but before you go I do just
want to say that I think what you're
doing is super important I love that
you're using your voice in this way and
also giving other people a platform to
use their voice too so I hope that you
continue we are Avid listeners um and
truly enjoy it so thank you for coming
on my show I appreciate absolutely
absolutely podcast pep or uh season 2 is
coming soon love that stay on the
lookout for that lot of great guests
will be on that uh card as well so thank
you of course thank you and again hey
thanks for the trip to thanks
Clippers thanks Pa I appreciate it thank
[Music]
you